so we are here with Sean Conlon but the
host of the deed and also a very
obviously well-known for your real
estate mogul with things which I cannot
like wait to talk about it figure out a
little bit more about your background
good good thank you lovely to be here
obviously I'm being your nice home you
have here your very counsel Nancy thank
you for that it's an old house but I
like it it's very very beautiful place
oh so you're an immigrant you can you
from you know a similar kind of a
Gregory's from a little bit more about
your support for him more chili let's go
what's your story
okay well firstly obviously you're an
immigrant too she'll understand my story
so what makes America great still I am
from the same places Conor McGregor
without the fighting ability I'd like to
think I dress a little better also but
obviously is incredible talent yeah I
come from Ireland I emigrated to America
in 1990 I'm that generation as your
parents were that America is the place
you can be anything you want I still
believe that it adds and flows once in a
while but generally speaking anything
you want and I rocked up to America in
1990 and I worked as a janitor actually
I'm embellishing my resume I would
actually be efficient to the janitor you
system yeah and I was terrible I was
really bad at chattering and I started
selling real estate in 1993 and the rest
is kind of my story so what month in
nineteen ninety day lectures I think the
end of September guessing roughly if I
remember correctly was a time in
November 28 1990 seriously while in Iran
for 10 years two years in Germany at a
refugee camp and in November 28 1998
came here America but I was listening to
your story in like nineteen nineties
imagine
you and I obviously read your story and
again it's what makes Americans firing
right about it so how did you get into
real estate how did that whole you know
process take place which so I when I was
working as the part-time assistant
janitor whatever I was I wasn't very
good at it I always had a passion for
real estate growing up in Ireland a lot
of people don't know but historically
till the late 1800s Irish Catholics were
not allowed own real estate so we have
this obsession about owning property so
I was always fascinated by real estate
and my dad would drive me buy with a
friend to look at these big old
beautiful castles and I was just
fascinated by them so I decided it was a
real estate part-time and I was really
not good at it and I cold called I would
do it every night after work at the
janitor and sounded cold call
people I'm Ida funny actions I don't
know I like to have a bit of an accent
but it would be like honey that guy who
sounds like lucky chance is on the phone
again and I would religiously call these
people and for six months I didn't sell
anything and I nearly gave up every day
yeah nearly gave up every day I never
really gave up because I get up the next
day I'm like this is the day and you
know what one day it was I mean I did a
twenty thousand dollar deal I called it
for sale by owner and by the end of the
90s I was selling nearly two hundred
million dollars a year although all by
myself yeah I said back when million
dollar listings were not shows I
probably they said sold more realistic
than anybody in North America in the
late 90s they said you're the Godfather
of conversation comes together in
Chicago King to Godfather anything is a
dubious honor but I'll take it
so your full-time doing your assistant
general yeah looks like a nine-to-five
job you got so it was like actually
probably 8 a.m. to like closer to 6:00
then I would get in and back before I
knew what like moisturizer was or
face wash I would clean the paint off me
with paint thinner
is a petroleum-based thing that's
getting the off of all blotchy red ants
are cold calling with my little headset
it's one of the things I salsa which I
thought was fascinating is you said you
love Saturdays yes Sundays because you
could work from 9:00 to 10:00 in the
real estate office I again I I would say
there is no magic right so I just worked
really hard and you know of course
there's serendipity and look involved in
some things I can't play to where it
came in from me in the 90s I've
subsequently seen all sorts of Lux and a
lot of was bad but summer was very good
the 90 nights I didn't get lucky I
really just worked very hard but yes
Saturdays and Sundays I could drive
around to open houses and then I all the
real brokers by asking stupid questions
they say there knows cubic uestions I
invented a whole load of 19 so you're
obviously of the work ethic yeah not the
word Ratigan and what did I work at the
companies that did you have an example
where you're watching you it's
interesting so my father was the most
charismatic man in the world and the
most wonderful dream in the world so as
an inspiration he was everything he was
everything that inspired me except he
was a horrendous businessman everything
he touched turned to dog really he
actually started businesses with it
little bit with every one of them failed
he fell down way I mean there wasn't you
know yeah I mean God he he was but he
was a dreamer and he poured all of his
belief even though those five kids he
poured all of his belief into me that I
was going to be the one now my mother
no nonsense to jobs schoolteacher raised
five kids in the small house I mean so I
got my mother's angry work ethic and
obviously she's an incredible woman and
I got my father's charm and charisma and
America was made for that at the time
you came here by your career I came by
myself I had a fourth or fifth day you
just said I'm coming out here what was
the transition so I dropped out of
college and on and went to work in
London and I worked actually at Lehman
Brothers in London
it's not my fault I didn't before rate
the company okay I didn't create the
issues I had a very non important job
there and then I loaded mail trains at
night in London but I'm standing in the
train platform one day and I'm like I'm
going to be average the rest of my life
and there was a news headline about
something the SAF had done over the
whole yeah I do and a lot of moments you
reinvented this or I can remember to
this day I was standing in Paddington
Station and there's a news headline and
one the tabloids at the SAS as moderates
fortune favors the brave right that's
the motto I'm standing watching this
platform coming home from another
average day in my average life thinking
I'm going to be average to the rest of
my life if I don't do something that
scares me and puts me out of my comfort
zone so we had distant cousins here who
had come to visit us
I said can I come over and then I get
boom I came to America
that's done Donovan yes yes yeah and the
cool thing is the dominoes are fantastic
into this day and they did give me an
opportunity to be in the shift in
janitor but they gave me an opportunity
that makes fun of it that he did I was
super cool is his son and the grandson
of the guy who gave me my first job
worked for me at my real fit merchant
bank as a real estate i'ma watch their
faces about continues all startups yeah
exactly I'm giving back so could you go
back I mean how often have you gone back
and visited well so the the interesting
thing initially was like for four or
five years I I didn't get to go back I
could have enough money and stink-eye
paperwork and all the usual stuff and
everybody's back there no one came to
subsequently my brother Karen has come
to work with me and my sister was out
here but my mom was Emma back there but
my dad the first thing I ever did I've
done a lot of amazing things sense and
I've had dinner with kings and princes
and travel around the world I'm flown on
the Concorde but none of those things
they all pale in comparison to in 95 I
saved up a bit of extra money I had and
I went home and my dad used to walk me
by the Mercedes dealership and we looked
in the window and we he'd explained to
the car to me what the car
somebody really rich Olivia I bought a
Mercedes investment coolest thing I've
ever done she's surprisingly did you see
a problem I mean I we went up and we
looked at it and there was a surprise
what is cool I mean he died very young
he died in 2000 but he lived long enough
to see me do everything he ever dreamed
of and then some so that's the coolest
thing I've ever done in my life bar none
there's nothing even to touch it like
this yeah just just three months ago I
bought my I never stayed out and he
wouldn't lend to get a 1978 in around
he's still around and yet he still
around so it's a and how many of you
came over so how many of you came over
when you candle when I same we went from
Iran to Germany lived happily as my
parents got a divorce so my dad came to
Chicago first he left fearful countries
okay and then we came with my mom and my
sister okay we move to LA Katya hello
but the power of immigrants man would be
a fire that you know you have to now
when you would live in an Ireland what
was like how was America viewed when you
were there nothing was it the problem
was it like it's a great question
America I mean you know we're not going
to touch politics right now but America
is great doesn't need to be made great
again of course it has all of its
problems but there's nowhere in the
world there's no in the world that has a
more level playing field scale there's
no in the world you can do the things
with you growing up in Ireland we were
raised on America I wanted to be John
Wayne Cary Grant Clint Eastwood and
everything was America American your
mind was that Promised Land where you
could be anything right you could be
anything in it the local library
complained to my mother wants one of 12
I was reading too many books right it's
great
I read 20 books about our in house
cousins balcony but one thing I really
read a lot about what I read about
Andrew Carnegie
I read about Rockefeller yeah in in the
library I want to be book some walkers
yeah 12 and 12 13 14 I read these well
as an element
was it because your dad would say look
because y'all look it's a huge thing
that bang-ups your dad was getting your
dreams yeah yeah my yes yeah my dad but
he didn't know he wasn't doing intense
he's like come here Shani look at this
and he called me Shani like come in
Sonny look at this he's like that's an
American guy has that and anytime
anything was big or amazing my father
back after America so it was in my mind
so it showed you the impact you can have
on kids and children with the right
positive message and reading I still
tell people you need to read would your
dad tell you to read with no knowledge
ever show me but ironically my dad who
dropped out of school at 12 my mom was
very well educated my daddy taught at a
school of 12 read the paper from cover
to cover every day yeah and he could
tell you everything about America
everything and so internally he dreamt
of coming to America I was scared and he
nearly came want something I was coming
to interesting enough got killed in some
sort of mob hit in New York I kid you
not and my dad I fulfilled his dream and
he eventually came here and I lived in
this this is a modest place now I lived
in the I was like a guy who won the
Powerball lottery and my dad showed up I
was living at a 7,000 square foot house
I mean there's so many floors in the
thing yeah
that's why curiously little his son yeah
which does she delivered because the
sisters
well we have it yeah I have a skirt and
so do my siblings I'm an amazing family
that's so cool yeah it sounds like it
from here and by the way your mom's team
sounds like yeah the way you describe
your mom she sounds like this straw when
you see her speak she seems very strong
money she's not interested many many
years ago I was showing off to my mother
and I landed in the lawn of our modest
house in a black helicopter
she didn't come out of house I walk in
like a really big deal and she has a
paper bag he said did you see all of the
papers you blew into the neighbor's
house the Mangan's and hands me the bag
so to go to my three-piece Savile Row
suit and take up all the papers of the
law I love it so yeah I'm good with
everything she still looks at you Shawn
absolutely so let's transition so
you go from zero and we're at a point if
you saw the million dollars of
properties in order Realty would give
you plug you so 200 million into yeah
baby transition into start a business so
that's I got a selling I'll let me build
it so Sussex and Riley get started and
you do million building a gas of sales
yeah how did that kinda show so nineteen
so interesting you know people here talk
about me like I've been around for 100
years ago said I broke a real estate
from 93 to 99 December 99 I was done I
was the most prolific sounds can feed it
obviously I don't mean but I was the
most holistic broker in the city nobody
did or has done what I did and I am the
99 though to the former burnout at the
two pagers at the gordon gekko
cellphones I mean it was intense and
like I can't I can't I can get rich
doing this I can never get wealthy and I
need to headspace so I'm like I want to
do something in the space more creative
so I started so she can rally
interestingly enough it's going to sound
like I had the fastest horse and
carriage in the world because it seems
David now but we were one of the largest
users of blackberries in North America
which was a handheld device by the way
in 2003 one of the largest users of
blackberries corporately in North
America in the early 2000s I give every
one of my agents a blackberry and then
the other thing I did before I opened I
would run a full page ad every week
without the name of my company and just
a phone number and it would say
announcing a bold new vision for real
estate never put in parentheses I know
that sounds like a cause of addicts for
used car sales and then the next thing
is followed up with an ad I'm about to
clean up the face of real estate and
then in parenthesis I would say but I
need to find a gadget handleerror
exxon-valdez things so Randy's for about
a month and I was like what's going on
who is this yeah once a week like ten
twenty thousand apostle you know when it
was in print media was expensive and a
random for a month and then we opened
and the buzz and so much and classic the
real estate board wanted to sue me for
insulting Realtors
[Laughter]
I'm not going to take that cuz I love
Realtors so we may be different no I
mean you saw your compass there you
study people so what made you different
so we'll go back to the beginning in the
conversation so I came at it as an
immigrant from the outside so immigrant
or outsider you look at things
differently so I looked at this business
where there's no limit on what you can
make
but people have no accountability you as
a broker sometimes you stay in bed if
you want and you're coming I approach it
like this was the greatest job
opportunity they had in my life
I wore a suit every day I wore a tie
every day I behaved like a just often
the job you know Goldman Sachs JP Morgan
so I approached it with a discipline I
ran it like a business and subsequently
that became a self-fulfilling prophecy
it became a very good business so I came
at it at the contrarian which I always
have done with everything I've ever done
and invariably you're wrong sometimes
but when you're right or really right
you only got to be right back yeah like
I'm going I'm going today to visit a
friend in the Hamptons and he's the guy
who broke Enron Jim Janus
he was the greatest short sell in the
world and you think how long he was
wrong till he was right on Enron think
how long he was wrong and China till he
was right he's sure Tesla you it's a
scary place to be a contrarian because
that warm feeling you feel generally you
know that is the center of the herd when
you're cold and scared
you're probably in front of the herd you
could be behind the herd but you're not
in it and so him in the short summer he
takes that to a whole nother level
yeah let's say that's a whole different
story it's like a whole other movie what
was a big short so he's in a gym chain
this event also this is a part of the
story
and one of the big monster guys in short
at the market yeah nobody believed them
until it really happened yeah so one
last question before we need you tell us
a little bit about data and we'll wrap
so you build a company then you start
recruiting real estate agents right what
did you look for when recruiting agents
or what do you look at that look all
right so when I started traffic in
Raleigh which is the forerunner to
Commonwealth a which we are now I hired
non brokers I heard people who had not
been in the business so we were quite
famous at the time for building this
huge company without brokers because I
was an outsider I was somewhat treated
like an outsider which makes me somewhat
of an Orwellian character I like to be
an outsider maybe to have perceived
enemies in my head just to be honest
with you
so it's fine I'm going to be an outsider
I people who came from McKinsey company
law firms JP Morgan I mean they came
from every walk of life but they were
hungry they were professional and they
were going to behave like real estate
investment advisers that's what I said
we are we are not Realtors you know in
that sense it's obviously a great brand
will not brokers your real estate
investment advisers or your real estate
advisers you're going to be the lifelong
adviser and real estate and that's what
I got and I built a company grew two
billion dollars in 14 months in sales
I'm new you know supporting yeah and was
incredibly successful at the time you
know as far as profitability to got so
if I wanted to be one of your top guys
what are three things you told me to
focus on so I would say firstly show up
on time for our interview tell me how
hard you work so this is the interview
process and obviously just genuinely
care to be successful real estate I
would make it much simpler there's no
magic my top agents work the most
there's no magic you tell everybody
which in the business you show up in
time you dress smart you treat it like
it's the biggest investment people are
ever going to make it's not a part-time
job but hard work there's no magic and
read everything you can about real
estate educator so yeah and read The
Wall Street Journal if you can every day
some of it or the New York Times or but
you know one little bit about every
going on very relevant that would be my
advice
I like that in last but not least the
shoulder these yeah that come about and
tell us a little bit about it so the
show came about because of serendipity
so when I say I've had luck and some
luck and some not that's true
serendipity back when I was the
assistant janitor I would have got a
bonus if I turned people in who were not
on the leaf so they fell in the building
called Bob title and he wasn't on the
lease so I could have turned him in and
even nickname for me subtitles because
he said I didn't speak English so I
really should turn to him but I loved
them and he goes off the time seller
moving Los Angeles he comes back in 94
he tells this story beautifully when he
spoke at a college he comes back in 94
and he's like he's 10,000 short for
making his movie and he sees a Range
Rover coming down the street in 94 he's
like drug dealers had come and rappers
maybe and he's like it stopped who gets
out of subtitles he's like I'm assuming
subtitles we've got a really good
drug-dealing gig going on and he kept
yeah in Chicago he tells me what he's
doing and I'm I got this I take a check
out of her to write a check in the heart
of the couch which I did so he went off
and led barbershop men of honor
biggie 2pac I mean he met a slew of hits
he married the first native-born 10
minutes of Bermudas daughter I'm the
Godfather to the kid were best friends
for this day we sit on the beach on my
house in Malibu some some Christmas from
we looking at each other like really and
he brought me in to CNBC with him I was
his real estate advisor and he's like
you guys you guys should do something
and here we are and it's really cool
because it's it's what I have done
anyway so it's very real I lend my own
money yeah yeah there are difficulties
what we probably didn't emphasize enough
it be
we've done all those deals now and
they've worked and the people's gotten
their money out and stuff like that and
I've gotten paid back it's actually a
great process and it's really exciting
and the end though we didn't get to show
like a lot of these people are static
they've done it and they're going to do
it for a living so it's great it's a
real the beach
cargo is a real real shelf and it's very
different a bit with so much writing
experience yeah yeah somebody and
there's no script yeah there's no script
and the things I tell them it's not
because I read it I've met all these
mistakes I've had these things happen to
me
that's good that's what I like about
that sure well listen this has been a
pleasure thank you like I'm very
interesting guys so I Conor McGregor
with versus made with what do you do you
think incentive jams like hell let me
tell you something to the greatest
businessman ever I don't care who loses
right I take that site because okay
knocking out in the first minute seconds
right so it's a fascinating thing
because the age differential I mcgregor
psychologically is a you know a three
fighter who a fantastic story by the way
fantastic Arthur he came from a really
poor place for all the showmanship he's
a real pro may were that I was probably
in our artist right I mean this is
something like he's yeah he didn't I
mean he's you know he's psychologically
you knows how to play defense but it'll
be an amazing one I can't call it I'm
not going to call him you know okay but
I'm up from aggregor on victory so I'm
hoping for a shocking ending with
McGregor getting a left one ended but
we'll see what's going to happen I'm not
going to call us yeah but I'm obviously
out for McGregor of course it is
wonderful I didn't mean to discount as
outfit he dresses like the most
wonderful Squire ever in his suit I
don't have you know yeah it's on a show
that we show he's a brilliant show -
yeah both of yeah well yeah I like it
yeah well the Americans treatment thank
you so much thank you nobody to make
sure we thank you very honored to be on
your show so thanks a lot
yes so you can go look him up and study
he's got a real good story but thank you
for your talk show thank you very much I
do appreciate it thank you guys
[Music]